some girl came up to us at the
meet-and-greet in in New Haven just just
the last show we did two days ago and
she was like I haven't done this since
magcon oh yeah yeah it was crazy and we
were like you went to magcon she was
like yeah I went there when I was 16
yeah and I was really how well do you
now she was like I'm 20 what that right
yeah yes yeah that's funny now and so we
were like I want the [ __ ] mag going
okay so a whole oh I got a tangent so we
asked her we're like what was that
madcon [ __ ] like and I had never seen
I'd seen a couple of those videos and I
didn't realize that and I don't know if
everyone knew this except me maybe I'm
late to it I didn't realize madcon dudes
would wrap their hands around these
girls heads and kiss their thumbs yeah
they would put their thumbs over the
girl's lips lips and then kiss their
thumbs
that's this what oh yes bring your kid
to that how do you watch that and not
flip your [ __ ] yeah I would be like get
your [ __ ] hands off my daughter young
man you get your hands off my daughter
that wants to happen dude that must have
happened it's so creepy dude hot strange
as hell in it and so like we asked her
we're like was it creepy and she goes
yeah oh my what would they say she's
like they would like hug you like around
your head and like bring you in which is
already way too intimate and they would
always say other like oh you're so cute
yeah are like carefully turning me on
god damn it bro you're so cute Oh bro I
don't care I don't care how attractive
you think any of them dudes were you
should not be talking like that to a
[ __ ] 16 year old dude yeah
you're 18 I mean they were there were 16
Oh were they I'm thinking they're older
I'm thinking they're like 20 but it's
still so like condescending yeah and
it's still such like a power yeah words
like oh you're here to visit me yeah
yeah
so predator
isn't it a little bit man yes so we
started going down magcon dudes
instagrams which is kind of interesting
dude like you how did they not know that
that [ __ ] was only for a year
had they not know yeah I know that and
you know what's crazy is that the own
like so the only one that's really like
insanely successful as Shawn Mendes reah
and apparently he would just in the
green rooms and [ __ ] before the magcon
shows he just be in the corner playing
on his guitar at the whole time and
never talked to anyone and then would
like do real [ __ ] on stage yeah play
music yeah and then go back to just
playing his guitar like he wasn't one of
the dudes I was like oh
dudes were drinking and like [ __ ]
yeah just like yeah treating it like
they're rock stars exactly you just oh
man what a terrible mess is that [ __ ]
whole event sent dude if you're uh if
you're a creepy attractive dude you
could be rich every creepy attractive
dude in high school is like oh hell yeah
dude just [ __ ] home become magcon
dude you're so cute let us say that to
somebody at RV IV the same how quick we
get yeah we do the kiss thing too right
only to the guy's foreheads now first we
dab them up why what's up bruh damn you
looking so cute another forehead kiss
him on the forehead and then we Boop
noses
so good to see you again so much for
coming in and then we grab their ass and
we take the picture one hand on each
cheek and we throw up the soup deuce and
we go get out of here enjoy the show
sport just support
good game fella mmm
what's up bud we'll see you out there
get out there get out there just the
most inappropriate VIP holy [ __ ] dude
they're in our underwear like not even
close yo what are you guys a what's good
what's up so I thought we could take a
prom picture oh no you in front did
that's disgusting dude get on my
shoulders yeah can I get sketchy Ella
you know what's funny is at this point
we've seen a lot of people come through
the VIP and I would say about half at
least are in college hmm if not older I
mean every single one of them goes I'm
the oldest person here I know y'all
can't just look around dude people who
are drinking at her shows are like we're
the only ones drinking it's like you're
not actually yeah this is this I don't
know and then she gets me just look
around they're just they're there you're
not alone dude
[Music]